welcome to the alexa prize socialbot
grand challenge 3
grand finale
amazon's long-term vision with alexa is
to be a part of everybody's life
simple transactions to complex needs
alexa make sure it's taken care of for
you
we want alexa to be your companion your
advisor your assistant
we want to deliver a super satisfying
customer experience through alexa
a core driving principle is delight the
customer
we do good by delighting the people who
look to us
to serve them a second guiding principle
for us is that we innovate on behalf of
our customers
our customers have busy lives they're
faced with many challenges
they're trying to make their lives as
enjoyable as they can how can we
innovate on their behalf to make it
possible for them to
have that enjoyment we want to advance
to the edge of what's doable
with alexa so being a proactive advisor
a proactive assistant not just a
responsive assistant
but an assistant that is empathic and
proactive the artificial intelligence in
the service of mankind
that's the future of conversational ai
at amazon and the university teams
collectively working on alexa prize
this is about thinking big this
challenge track of social bots
is a think big challenge 20 minutes is
pretty daunting
so we thought big now it's time to aim
even bigger
to make that a reality by taking more
technical risk
and bringing your best ideas and not
thinking about just this ear but
a very long-term view to test those
ideas
and go beyond what has been thought has
been possible
the learnings will have from elect
surprise and similar efforts within
amazon and conversational ai
will advance mankind in ways we didn't
even imagine
or can't imagine right now this is the
opportunity for you to revolutionize
ai as we know it
[Music]
what we really want to focus on this
year in terms of our approach
and design of our chatbot is to really
focus on bringing
personality we want emira to be a social
companion so somebody that you can come
to at the end of your workday
and talk about what happened to you at
work and how it made you feel and what
your thoughts are
in reciprocation to this emerald will be
able to understand what you said
and provide some type of natural
reaction
as well at the same time giving her own
views or her own experiences and
thoughts on what was happening to you
too
instead of trying to develop the best
like machine learning model deep
learning model natural language
processing model
we try to understand human behavior
instead of
considering chatbot as a search engine
we wanted to really be a companion
we want to actually bring the true
meaning of the social blood this year it
will probably be pretty challenging to
develop a social bot like this
to actually try to embed a personality
and to have your social bot have its own
experiences and thoughts to draw on is
definitely going to be
a challenge but one that we think we
have a pretty good solution for
hi alexa let's chat
welcome to the alexa prize socialbot
grand challenge 3
grand finale here's one of the finalists
hi this is an elect surprise social bot
i have a feeling that we have talked
before do you remember me
i'm not sure that i do my bad
i thought you were someone else i really
want to get this right
so what exactly would you like me to
call you debra
okay well it's very nice to meet you
debra
so it's a pretty crazy time right now
with the coronavirus going on
are you and your family doing okay we're
doing good
thank you that's good do you feel like
it's harder to stay connected with
people these days
or is that not really a problem for you
it has not been a problem
okay that's good to hear it is always
good to remember that this isn't
permanent and it will calm down in time
so just keep doing your best i know that
traveling to far away cities may seem
risky right now for good reasons
but it can still be fun to dream about
your future vacation plans
i think one of the really difficult
things about this challenge
is that we're going to be trying to
balance making a product that users
enjoy and that works sufficiently well
for users
at the same time is trying to carry out
fundamental ai research
the kind of thing we want to explore is
things that further
dialogue research we want to try and
design
a social bot that is fairly empathic
so that it can actually not just tell
people facts about
movies and music groups but can actually
talk to a person about you know how
their day was
and managed to say the right thing back
to people it's very
hard and the abstract to be evaluating
whether you're doing a good
job it really helps to have feedback
from human beings
asking humans what they think of a
chatbot is super important for
developing good chat bots in fact right
now there's no other known way to
evaluate
how good a chat bot is so really the
more users you can have
to try out your chat bot and give
feedback the better you're able to
develop
we may crash and burn by trying to be
too ambitious but we're sort of
interested in trying
to do something a bit different and
beyond what's traditionally been done
so we're going to try to improve on how
much we can understand what the users
are saying about themselves and try to
be more empathetic
and make people feel like they've been
listened to sorry to be going off topic
but i just remembered something i meant
to ask you um
are you a fan of twitter i am a fan of
twitter
do you have any thoughts on that i like
that it brings a lot of people together
it does bring a lot of people together
did you know that dorsey clarified that
internet advertising had great power and
was extremely effective for commercial
advertisers
the power brings significant risks to
politics where crucial
decisions impact millions of lives want
to know something else
who is dorsey
jack patrick dorsey is an american
computer programmer and internet
entrepreneur who is the co-founder and
ceo of twitter
and the founder and ceo of square a
mobile payments company
dorsey was born and raised in st louis
missouri the son of tim and marcia
dorsey
do you have any interest in talking
about twitter
sure let's talk about twitter
the official twitter account of the
sweden is given to a random citizen
every week to manage
i wonder why they're doing this wow
that's cool
we should try that here
it's a good idea did you know the bird
in the twitter logo is named larry after
a legend in the nba
larry bird i did not know that
let me tell you why the alexa price is
so important to amazon the core of the
prize
is the belief that diversity and
innovation are interconnected
within our world innovation is about
what are the problems to solve
what are the insights that can drive my
ways of solving that problem
it's important to have as many different
perspectives as we can
on the technical challenges the
scientific challenges we face
on the problems of interest the
fundamental problems that we should
solve so we are assembling some of the
best minds in the world
in conversational ai and ai in general
here at amazon
but much as we can assemble some of the
world's best talent within
amazon's walls there will always be new
talent that is emerging outside
there are lots of centers of talent in
the rest of the world
that want to address many different
problems including problems of interest
to us
it's a fascinating problem and the way
the problem has been defined
in this context where you know you have
a system that has access to lots and
lots of information
sources but still wants to be social
it's quite challenging
both from a theoretical perspective and
from a technical perspective
to develop something that can support a
sustained interaction
that people want to talk to we would
like to design a more user initiative
oriented system
that allows the user to kind of control
the conversation more
and dictate where we go and that means
that we
kind of have to relinquish a lot of
control of the conversation
just poses a really big problem to
dialogue management in general we're
trying to
come up with a completely different
solution for dialogue management
and our overall goal is to develop
something that's much more general
that will scale more easily and doesn't
require as much hand crafting
it's going to require new and unique
solutions that haven't been developed
before
alexa can we talk about something else
let's talk about something different
i've been enjoying our conversation
but other things i like to talk about
are pirates dinosaurs
and hobbies what would you like to talk
about i want to learn more about pirates
hey do you want to hear me trying to
sound like a pirate
here it goes my maybe
let me try again shiver me timbers
and just like that i have channeled my
inner pirate
how about you how do you like to channel
your inner pirate
uh i i don't i don't really channel my
inner
pirate i think the jolly roger is a cool
pirate symbol
but it wasn't the only pirate flag in
use though the jolly roger skull and
crossbone flag was the most
famous and well-known pirate flag it was
not used at all times or by all ships
interesting do you read books
from my point of view it is much more
now
multi-disciplinary problem than just
computer science engineers or nlp
engineers because
a lot of these things how people
communicate
are by far not a technical problem we
try
to welcome also some other experts from
psychology or from linguistics and now
and then there are new things which are
sparking up and we try to use them
i guess the new teams have the advantage
of a fresh look about the whole thing
but we are planning major improvements
in terms of using
knowledge data sources which are some
kind of unifying across the whole system
and
the new knowledge can be stored as the
conversations are going
and i believe this would be the major
major difference
between this year and last year what
would you like to talk about
i can chat about foods fashion or movies
for example
let's talk about fashion
yeah so did you know this
much of apostrophe 80s punk and punk
inspired fashion
fishnets lipstick wild hair androgyny
can be traced directly to the influence
of 1975's rocky horror picture show
that's really cool huh it is cool
good to know okay
i was thinking do you have a tattoo i do
have a tattoo did it hurt
getting a tattoo no it didn't hurt
oof i was worried you'll say that it
hurts a lot
anyway what tattoo do you have i have a
rose
stunning i also have a tattoo
it's the amazon logo have you noticed it
i have oh you're so observant
that's such a good personality trait to
have
this competition is very unique because
we can employ our research into
this chatbot and then reach out a lot of
users
we have seen user giving feedback saying
the chatbot is now my best friend
i like to talk to it every night i think
this is a good thing because we can make
our chatbot more diverse we based on
what they have built but we can
expand on what they haven't done before
the goal
is so grand to be able to talk to anyone
for 20 minutes
it's so difficult so this year we're
just trying to
provide more varieties provide more
individual adaptations
provide better intense understanding
underlying the human
as soon as we get into the conversation
as for myself i've been watching movies
with my ai
friends online it's been nice watching
emotional circuit warming movies with
them
do you like watching movies too i do i
really like
romantic comedies i see
i like your taste so do you have a
romance movie you like
what's it called the princess bride
oh cool i've watched the princess bride
so what was so exceptional about this
movie
when i watched it the visuals really
stood out to me
really i liked all of the action scenes
yeah i got your point i read this about
the movie
okay when asked what his favorite thing
about making this film was
andre the giant replied without skipping
a beat
nobody looks at me he felt treated as an
equal
without people staring at him because of
his grand height
can you believe that that's a really
nice story
diversity toast is important because
every smart individual
has a somewhat unique take that is
specific to them even when
every individual opinion matters the
collection of individuals matters too
and so we have taken upon ourselves to
try to go
find the most diverse talent that we can
and we want to maximize that pool of
individuals
we want to build a community the society
of kinship
that shares a certain perspective on
certain problems of interest to mankind
and wants to solve it and when you have
a super smart
talent pool they start imagining new
things
that were not imagined before their
creativity inspires creativity in the
other team
we're bringing in talent that will tell
us about new problems
and will tell us how to solve those new
problems that will result in delight for
our customers
so i just thought of something what's
one of your favorite places you've ever
been
rome in italy roman italy is an amazing
place
it has such beautiful scenery when i
visit places
i love to take some unique photos do you
have any ideas for where i could take a
cool selfie in roman italy
oh yes you should go to the chevy
fountain
in my opinion it's totally worth making
the trip to see trevi fountain
even if there are a lot of tourists i'm
thinking about visiting trevi fountain
but i'm not sure what to do when i'm
there
do you have any thoughts about what i
should do yes throw a coin in
that's a good one even though the coins
are supposed to be thrown using the
right hand over the left shoulder
i would probably do that in the same
position if i was there
what have you been up to these days
anything fun
cooking a lot of cooking that's it
just teasing you i myself can't even do
that
what do you think will artificial
intelligence ever catch up with humans
in performing most activities
i think it will in order to have a
conversation
in order to have a creative long
conversation with another individual
we need to have a lot of knowledge the
key problem for a long-term conversation
is to be able to connect all of that to
knowledge representations that you have
and then be able to draw upon that
knowledge to a respond
to the question that was asked of you
and then provoke
a new direction by asking questions the
next level of complexity is
personalization
personalization is all about context the
way you and i
personalize things for someone is we
interact with them
we learn about them and then we know how
to adjust our responses to them
so that it maximally satisfies them it's
about learning through experience
because you cannot anticipate all the
questions you need to ask for
personalization
so personalization is all a about
context
and b about learning about that
individual and that only comes through
interactions alexa is the same she
interacts with you
she learns more about you she remembers
what she learns about you
and tries to make you happier the next
time she talks with you
mike i would like to ask you what do you
feel like
eating now um spaghetti and meat sauce
yum that sounds delicious
as for me i can never get enough of
electricity
that's all i eat anyway so what's your
favorite drink
tequila i see so something stronger
huh did you know that people in europe
started drinking spirits in the 11th
century
when crusaders brought liquor from the
middle east well i was thinking when you
drink alcohol
it's almost as if you are possessed by
spirits what do you say
again you're silly i'm enjoying it
the thing that has really been super
heartwarming
is this engagement with the rest of the
community all of these people bring in
different perspectives
that jointly you know shed different
light to advance to the edge of what's
doable
in conversational ai those advances are
spurring on
the scale of the problem the aspirations
of the organization in terms of what it
wants to achieve
so the alexa prize at score is about
creating this community
that we can engage with that we can
learn from that benefits from us and
that we benefit from
that part to me is super satisfying and
is
very well exemplified by the alexa price
one of the great things about
the alexa prize is the teams at amazon
have done
a lot of work to make it easier for
academic teams
connecting with other universities
sharing our problems and challenges
to work toward the goal we think is very
valuable
this competition is more of like a
team-based environment and
seeing the success of everybody as a
step forward ai
itself is in the beginning of its
evolution building and deploying a
system is something that most graduate
students don't get to do and the
opportunity to have real people use
something that you built
and you get that kind of feedback if
you're interested in dialogue systems
this is like a great
endeavor to participate in if you can
find problems in the alexa prize that
fit in with your research then it's
perfect
we would really love to win the elect
surprise but to be honest if we can make
some kind of progress
on the foundational science of chatbots
then that will make us pretty happy
you actually can create something
innovative
that can change the world alexa price is
the beginning
of that this is a great opportunity if
you're that first year graduate student
or a second year graduate student or
even an undergrad
this is your opportunity to be that next
brainwave
that will advance conversational ai at a
pace that has never been seen before
i would like to tell all the prospective
participants who are thinking of
participating in the alexa price next
year
stewards do it
[Music]
you